las tensiones en el estrecho de formosa
en los últimos años y que se han
agudizado en las últimas semanas
responden a la confluencia de dos
factores por un lado en taiwán gobierna
el partido democrático progresista
partidario de mantener las distancias
con pekín al contrario que la otra gran
formación histórica al comité que
defiende un acercamiento progresivo y
condicional no extraña pues que las
relaciones bilaterales no hayan dejado
de degradarse desde que sainz when
ganara las elecciones en 2016 el otro
gran factor es la actitud estadounidense
donald trump durante los últimos meses
de su mandato cuando se dedicó a pesar
de todos los calles a china- estrecho
las relaciones diplomáticas con tape y
firmó importantes ventas de armas no
parece que la política haya cambiado con
yo bailé que a finales de marzo y afirmó
su gran primer acuerdo contra el pay lo
que fue respondido por pekín con el
envío de aviones militares sobre su área
de exclusión
taiwán es la gran asignatura pendiente
de china desde que los nacionalistas de
chiang kai-shek se refugian en la isla
tras perder la guerra civil con los
comunistas de mao su reunificación es
prioritaria y si sin fin su presidente
quería pasar a la historia como el
artífice pero nada hace pensar hoy que
esté cerca de conseguirlo